this man gave me so much pleasure uh
when i watched him
for my alma mater go crush it and then
in his decade and a half in the national
football league was
uh awesome to watch him grow into a
grown-ass man that has earned him
the uh right to be called a finalist for
the 2021 pro football hall of fame class
um interestingly enough he might go into
the hall of fame with a man who he beat
out for the heisman i know
peyton manning that'd be interesting
he's charles woodson here on the rich
eisen show how are you charles
rich man i'm doing fantastic man how are
you doing if i had told you
back in the day when you won the heisman
from peyton
if i told that charles woodson that the
two of you would be finalists of the pro
football hall of fame together in the
same class of 2021 you'd have said what
to me charles woodson
i would have said i believe you
that's the kind of confidence that i
have man yes indeed and
i believe he probably had he probably
had the same confidence so i would have
said you know what rich i believe you
man
we'll go into that going to the hall of
fame together one day you and
and it's it it's that i mean what did
what did you think of when you heard
that news
about being finalists in your first time
to possibly be enshrined here charles
you know uh rich man it's it's you know
it's special
um and i i would imagine for all the
players who
go through this process uh to see the
list come out see your name on that list
see all of the other great players that
have
gone through the league and then to see
your name as
a nominee you know for the hall of fame
for one it lets me know that man five
years has gone by pretty fast from the
last time that i was able to suit up
but then also man you look back over
your career
and what you were able to you know
accomplish
as a player at the highest level i think
is the ultimate respect for any player
just just to have that nomination to be
honest so
you know i'm very blessed man i i had an
unbelievable career played with a lot of
great players great coaches
and uh you know how great would that be
you know to get into the hall of fame
did you ever overlap with tai law at
michigan
or no he he proceeded to talk he left he
left early man i went up there on a
recruiting visit and got to meet him
one time before he left but uh ty was
out of there man he was on the bigger
bigger and better things okay and then i
guess the next time you saw him is when
he
he hopped on the bus after the tuck rule
game and he started
he started giving you crap for not
saying goodbye to him right charles did
that happen
yeah yeah yeah that was the last that
was the next time i saw him man i wanted
to chase him down the street for that
man but
yeah that's that's that's my boy though
man so it you know it'd be great too man
you know i was at the hall of fame when
he went in
and that was a special moment you know
to be there with one of my good friends
man and
you know share that moment with him and
his family and you know how great would
it be to have
you know two michigan wolverines two
corners
going to the hall of fame man and you
know lock it down in the hall of fame
too
yep and uh of course uh there'll be uh
one at quarterback coming up uh very
shortly and i i want to put a pin in uh
the conversation with tom brady with you
for a moment
uh but because i want to get to charles
woodson here on the rich eisen show
your visit to uh the new home of the las
vegas raiders you were there on monday
night
as part of your work with the show that
i host which is always thrilling to see
your name on the list of being a
correspondent for nfl the grind which is
the nfl films produced show
every wednesday night tonight on epics
at nine eastern time that
i host looking back at a couple of games
as well as the entire week while
flashing forward to
the next week and you were at the monday
nighter in
vegas what was that like charles walk me
through your night
there
yeah you know it was a lot of
anticipation you know for the game
for one because it's a big matchup you
know
oakland raiders is the first game you
know in the death star
that is a legion stadium going against
the new orleans saints who i know
you know people have their early picks
to be a contender
late in the season so it's a big matchup
but to have that first game
in vegas where nobody i don't
nobody that you would talk to would ever
say you talk about
me if you told me years ago would i be
in a hall of fame
well ask me the same question did i
think there'd ever be football in las
vegas
and to that question i would have said
no uh but here we are
you know in las vegas monday night
football and
to tell you how how big it is and
special it is
your fans aren't allowed in the stadium
right but fans still
showed up in las vegas just to be there
just because the game was being played
no kidding really yeah so that so that
goes to show you you know people want to
know about
raider fans and will they support the
raiders there were raiders fans
all over las vegas just to be in town
for the game
you know they watched the game you know
wherever they were at but
they were there there was a two-hour
wait in line to get inside
greater image you know the day before
the fans were ready
and and anticipating football in las
vegas so
the energy was there as far as being in
the stadium you know the stadium is
beautiful
you know they paid a lot of attention to
detail uh mark davis
was uh very adamant about um
you know having a local presence in the
stadium so there's there's local artwork
in there from people that are from las
vegas and then there's
you know restaurants as far as influence
from oakland bringing some of that
oakland influence into the stadium
uh paying homage to the old players um i
took a video of
some of the uh the old raiders the the
legends the hall of famers
beautiful display of their numbers and
their induction year
um of course the torch is enormous
and what a special night to have you
know mark davis's
uh mother sitting in front of that torch
and lighting the torch for the first
game in las vegas so
i mean it was it was special um
to be there you know for one to be there
and and
to me i felt like i was kind of
representing the fans and so i tried to
take as many videos as i could and give
them
a little insight to the stadium gave
them the video of the warm-up
as if they were in the stadium stadium
and watching their team warm up
so it was it was great man great night
and a great game
yeah sure was and i saw that i saw those
videos on your instagram at charles
woodson
um so let's get to that game because um
to me um a couple things left out and i
mentioned it yesterday
the mayok putting in gruden's hands
you got a monster at tight end you got a
monster at running back
you got a monster at defensive end and
you got a monster at safety
and there's there's monsters all over
the field and if this quarterback can be
decisive and mistake-free
um this team's gonna be uh difficult
to deal with charles what do you make of
that assessment
of the raiders having seen them
yeah i think i think you're right on i
think you know
gruen and mayor together have uh you
know accumulated
some good young talent and and
young talented guys who are who are
hungry you know
and you know this was uh groom's words
is that he has guys that
on the team that really love football
and uh you know that's important to have
that feeling about your guys
uh but when you talk about you know for
a quarterback
you know this is this is universal you
know your best friend is a good tight
end and a good running back
and boy does he have that in darren
waller you know he was
virtually you know unstoppable the whole
night ends up with 12
catches over 100 yards but you can see
his athleticism is so noticeable
on the field you know the way he can
catch turn
signs of the defender jump in and out of
tackles
he's a big guy of course that can run
through tackles but he has speed
so it doesn't matter who you put on him
you know he can have success
josh jacobs um i mean he he's tough man
he's built like a tank and one
interesting thing is that i you know i
was talking to malcolm jenkins
and you know i said hey you know you
guys held the running back you held josh
jacobs under 100 yards you know that's
usually a staple for defense that's what
you
hang your hat on and stop and run and
you know
his thing was yeah we we stopped him
from getting 100 yards
but it wasn't about that it was the
physicality
you know the physicality of the
offensive line and then also the
physicalness of
josh jacobs so you know they were i
think able to impose
their will a little bit um on the saints
in their run game
uh and then my you know my hat goes off
to you know the young rookie
wide receivers you know because those
guys are stepping into a situation where
you know there's really no veterans out
there on the field right now to
um you know well there's a few veterans
but not the kind of guys you would think
that that mentors those young guys and
they got to step in and start
you know edwards and rugs those guys are
starters on the team
a franchise that just moved over to
vegas and that's that's uh
you know that's a pretty pretty um hefty
load for those guys to carry and they
did it
i think from defensive standpoint you
talk about the safety abram man he's a
heat-seeking missile
he'll hear anything moving and he plays
with high energy that's what i'm
referring to
that's what i was talking about yeah so
i think yep so i think the only thing
defensively i would say man
is tackling i think was an issue uh
kamara
he pretty much had his way all day for
the most part you know
he was hard to handle so i think
tackling and angles and those sort of
things from a defensive standpoint is
what they'll have to work on going
forward
and next up for them is new england uh
i'm sure you saw what cam looked like on
sunday night football
why do you think cam was sitting at home
for as long as he was sitting at home
charles what do you think about that
subject
that's that's that's an interesting
question man um
the only thing i would say is maybe
people thought that he was too
too big a personality for the locker
room you know that's the only thing i
could say because
if you watch his career there's nothing
about his career
uh that would need you to say he was in
decline
of course he had you know some injuries
that he had to deal with um
shoulder i believe and some other
injuries but when you watch this guy
at his best you watch him healthy you
know he's one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl and i think he's
in the right place because i think
with bill belichick you know he he don't
mind bringing in
you know personalities you know he
brought in
you know a randy moss um you know
gronkowski's a personality he coached
great
players like lawrence taylor so he
doesn't have a problem bringing in guys
with big personality
um he knows how to get the best out of
you so i think some of these teams just
missed out on cam because they felt like
um his personality was too big and maybe
he would
lead some players in the wrong direction
but i know there's some teams
you know probably sitting back right now
thinking to themselves you know what
maybe we overthought that a little yeah
you think cause because 2015
cam has shown up in new england in 2020
and if
the patriots can just keep on keeping on
in the first year without tom brady any
team that let cam sit at home when they
could have used him
has nobody to blame except the to use
parcels phrase man in the mirror
you know that's it that that's it that's
exactly right you know and when they're
uh
marching into the playoffs and those
teams are sitting by
with whoever they brought in you know to
leave their franchise
they'll have they'll have to eat it i'm
making people eat it that's for sure
charles woodson here on the rich eisen
show let's return back to that monday
night you were at
what did you see when you watched drew
brees play on monday night
charles i thought that uh
you know there's really just for me one
play that that really
stuck out to me i know people have been
talking about how
he doesn't look the same but to me it
was it was the interception
uh and i remember you know watching it
play
and when he let it go i thought to
myself who is he throwing throwing it to
because
you know there wasn't it really wasn't a
saint
in the vicinity of course there was a
you know receiver probably five or six
yards behind
um the linebacker that caught the
interception
but it just it does that didn't seem
like you know vintage
drew brees to me you know bad bad
decision
um that that guy was clear as day
in the throwing pass and he threw the
ball right to him
and you know i just thought to myself
hey that doesn't look very
you know drew brees you know i thought
that they tried to
um they had you know they ran a lot of
crossing routes things that were right
in front of them
you know i didn't see them push the ball
down the field a whole lot
uh and i thought they tried to you know
keep the ball on the ground
uh for the most part early with kamara
but when the raiders you know started to
go on their
their run and running the clock out and
going down and scoring
a touchdown then they had to try to air
it out a little bit
and then you know he kind of came alive
late you know when the game was you know
kind of decided but to me i think that
one play that interception
was was not very uh drew brees like to
me
well i mean a part of the conversation
again
i i guess i shouldn't quote twitter it's
because twitter thinks breeze is done
um but uh that the interception by
nicholas morrow occurred because he was
camouflaged
in the raiders logo in the middle of the
field that he was wearing the same
uniform
color scheme as the paint on the field
and that brees might not have seen him
standing there literally because he's
camouflaged even though as you pointed
the guy was sitting there playing his
day
but brees after the game was talking
about you know essentially that he runs
the offense the way he's supposed to
essentially with what the defense was
giving him you saw the two
safeties back uh quite a bit um so i
guess put it all together
where do you stand on the subject of
breeze quote unquote being done
what did you see with your eyeballs well
i can't i can't
i can't i can't i can't ever put it on
one game rich
uh that's one game where you know he had
off night every player has off night um
i remember a few years back when when
brady had an off night um against the
kansas city chiefs and everybody was
riding him off he threw a couple of pigs
one to the touchdown
then i think they went on to win the
super bowl that year and he's still
playing football now
so i'm not going to write him off now
you know to think about
uh the game of football you know once
once the decline starts you know it'll
really start to expose you
so let's take this thing you know two
three weeks out
and see how drew brees is playing but
i'm not going to sit here
for one game and one night and say that
you know he's he's he's done charles i i
gotta
i got to see more of that charles
woodson here on the rich eisen show
and breeze so you know breeze is gonna
use all that conversation
uh to his advantage in his next game and
then let's just see if the
other quarterback in that game is also
got a chip on his shoulder hold on a
second oh yeah
it's aaron rodgers by the way i just put
my glasses on it's just a prop to see
uh my notes even though i didn't have it
written down
that was just a prop have you spoken
aaron rodgers lately
charles have you spoken him because
we're talking to him friday on this show
are you no not having a you know just
just briefly you know out at uh
in tahoe american century uh tournament
but yeah i haven't talked to him since
the season started well the narrative is
he's all pissed off about what happened
with the draft
and you know he's been really chill and
cool about it
he's been rel ax about it um
you know when he's been zooming and
talking publicly
but that deep down he's taking it out on
the rest of the league to show green bay
um
that he's got a lot of years left what
do you think of that subject matter
charles well i don't i don't think
aaron has to take it out on anybody
aaron's a good boy he's a great
quarterback so he's going to play well
you know regardless uh as far as
the packers taking um the quarterback
i don't feel like aaron rodgers was ever
threatened that that anybody could come
take his job so i don't think he's
truly mad about that i would i would
imagine that he's more mad that
you know you always talk about you know
green bay and or and having quarterbacks
like aaron rodgers and surrounding him
with with
the top talent and you know being that
there was a couple of receivers
that maybe they could have taken you
know bringing him another weapon
on that team i think that probably
bothered her more than them
drafted a quarterback but of course you
know you take a quarterback you know
it it kind of brings up the same
situation he was in
when he got drafted and farmers there so
you you automatically know okay
they brought a young guy in you know i'm
kind of getting towards the end
so there is a sense of urgency you know
for aaron rodgers it's like
okay i know i got a few years left i
gotta get to
i gotta get back to the super bowl i
think that's that's the main thing
that's on his mind
and not being about him you know taking
that taking it out on everybody because
the packers drafted a quarterback
all right and then last one for you
charles you're right there near the
corridor in tampa
um in florida how long do you think it's
going to take till we see
brady feel totally comfortable with
everybody around him
and start winning football games in the
manner that we're used to seeing
him win football games or you think that
might not come at all
what's your thoughts on that subject
yeah not yeah i think you get i think
you give
is no different than breeze as far as
seeing where he's at
right and his career i think it's the
same with brady you give this thing a
couple weeks you know this is sort of
like
you know going through uh you know
preseason having preseason games this is
his first time with the team
i thought the first week against the
same thing if you watched
you know the opening drive where he went
down and joe
drove the ball down the field went in
with the quarterback sneak
you know you know he still got it now
during the rest of the game i felt like
there was some timing there was some
miscommunication with him and the
receivers and i think
all the all of that comes with game
situations
so i think a couple more weeks of him
working with evans and godwin's coming
back i believe
uh seeing how they can work gronk and oj
howard
into the game plan uh i think we'll
start to see things click a little bit
more and i think we'll see
a little bit more of that vintage brady
before we'll see
the end of brady charles
i love seeing you on the grind can't
wait to see your work from vegas
uh on epics tonight at nine eastern time
best to your family how's the wine
business
let's talk about that before i let you
go how's it how's your great wine
business is is doing great man right
before you called i was on a call with
uh
intercept sales team man and you know
we're continuing to grow we've just
launched in south dakota north dakota
washington oregon so rich we are we are
we are growing man and uh i'm proud to
be a part of this team with uh
o'neill vintners out there in paso
robles so anybody looking intercept wine
interestingwine.com check it out type in
your zip code and see if
you can find it near you and uh
enjoy it's so good charles it really is
and i'm not just saying that because you
send me stuff without me asking
it's really it really is
it's it's the as you said what did you
say that uh
abrams booms everybody is that what you
basically said that that's the way the
wine hits
the pallet every single time it really
does yeah yeah even
thinking milford man he'll hear anything
moving he is thanks for the call charles
really appreciate it i look forward to
seeing you again tonight on epecs and
let's do this more often let's do it
thanks rich you better you guys charles
woodson future first ballon hall of
famer i'll say it
goat hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here